es sind 16 Sekunden die ballermann-star
Melanie Müller wohl die Karriere Kosten
werden in einem Video das Bild exklusiv
von einem ihrer Auftritte vorliegt sieht
man die Sängerin wie sie den Hitlergruß
zeigt mehrmals und das eindeutig es ist
ein Skandal und der tiefe Fall einer
trashikone
sind diese 16 Sekunden das Ende von
Melanie Müllers Karriere der 16 Sekunden
Clip der Bild zugespielt wurde zeigt wie
Müller vor mutmaßlichen Neonazis auf der
Bühne steht das Mikro in der rechten
Hand stimmt sie an Ost
Ostdeutschland ein Schlachtruf der
Fußballszene das mikrowandert in die
linke Hand Müller und die Menge
skandieren weiter Ostdeutschland dabei
reißt die Sängerin insgesamt acht Mal
den ausgestreckten jetzt freien rechten
Arm zum sogenannten Hitlergruß nach oben
Müller begründet das so mache seit elf
Jahren stehe ich auf der Bühne und mache
immer diese klimpf unangenehme
Handbewegung nicht aus rechtsradikalen
Hintergründen sondern zicke zacke zicke
zacke genau dort wie ich so mache
Rückblick bereits vor einigen Tagen
taucht ein Video auf bei einem Auftritt
von Melanie Müller brüllen Neonazis Sieg
Heil Recken dabei den rechten Arm
[Applaus]
doch anstatt den Auftritt abzubrechen
steigt Melanie Müller offenbar in das
widerwärtige Brille mit ein
[Musik]
das Video gelangt ins Internet ein
Aufschrei der Empörung schlägt Melanie
Müller entgegen Deutschland fragt sich
wie rechts ist Melanie Müller die
dementiert sofort
deutlich davon kritisiere diese
schändlichen
[Musik]
einzelkonzertbesuche und habe es
aufgrund diesen
ausrufen natürlich auch sofort
abgebrochen beendet alles Lüge Mimik und
körpersprachenexperte Matthias Ehlers
Urteil ist eindeutig das Dementi des
Schlagerstars ist nicht glaubwürdig
zugrunde 19 sie kommt ins Straucheln
nimmt Abstand lehnt sich zurück
vernuschelt sich vermutlich weil es ihr
nicht gelegt den Text abzulesen und die
Wörter schändlich und unentschuldbar
auch noch nie vorher gelesen hat
kritisiere diese schändlichen
[Musik]
also Konzertbesuche wie rechts ist
ballermannsdam Melanie Müller also dazu
Müller gegenüber Bild ich bin weder
Rechts organisiert
ich weiß es nicht keine Ahnung war ich
das jemals
fakt ist dass Melanie Müller bereits vor
Jahren mit Rechten ausländerfeindlichen
Aussagen im Internet auffällt bereits
2017 schlägt ihr deshalb ein Shitstorm
entgegen fakt ist auch die Location in
der Müller auftrat gilt als Heimstatt
der Rockergruppe Rowdies Eastside
offenbar kein harmloser Motorradclub vom
sächsischen Verfassungsschutz heißt es
viel mehr wir wissen dass Einzelpersonen
aus der Leipziger rechtsextrem
Hooliganszene dort Kontakte pflegen auch
die Polizei interessiert sich für das
neue hitlergruß-video alle verfügbaren
Aufnahmen von dem Abend werden vom
Staatsschutz analysiert und die
Beteiligten befragt Strafanzeige wegen
Verwendens von Kennzeichen
verfassungswidriger Organisationen sei
von Amts wegen bereits am Montag
gestellt worden das endgültige Ende von
Melanie Müllers Kar eine Karriere die
als Pornoqueen beim Bachelor begann eine
Karriere die er zu Dschungelkrone und
zum Promi Big Brother Sieg verhalten
eine Karriere die Müller seit Jahren als
partysängerin am Ballermann viel Geld
einbrachte und nun der Hitlergruß
eigentlich soll sie am Mittwoch in
Dresden beim Oktoberfest Auftreten der
Auftritt wird vermeintlichen
beiderseitigem Einvernehmen abgesagt
Bild erfährt der Veranstalter hat Müller
zur Absage gedrängt der tiefe Fall einer
trashy-krone
[Musik]